what is lovely because acting is a kind
of transient thing you meet people then
you don't but one of the lovely things
we come out of these films is your
friendship with Ian McKellen but you
must have known Ian McKellen before the
films oh yes since I was a teenager he's
two years older than me
he said something the other day really
along with what he was just said one of
the nicest things ever
he said yeah Patrick Stewart and I I
really feel that last I have a brother
that's torille he might have said father
you I you I've kind of a theory about
the way he speaks the way in McKellen
speaks what we did an animated movie
together as well as these you did yeah
it was called flushed away I really love
my son often says why was there no
sequel to that mystery cuz I've lost a
lot of money but he played the tow route
ah a loser I was always like he can get
like consonants where there's nothing
like he can make a one syllable word
into 20 okay it is a test for you is
your test for you if you shut your eyes
yes okay is this the real voice of you
McCallum or is it somebody doing in
mechanik okay Graham is there room for
another mutant on that sofa of yours
what's real
[Applause]
[Music]
why I'm just as I am I've just come down
from Scotland and it took longer to get
from sit down you're very welcome
more to tell you about microphone I was
at kakadu high school telling them to be
nice to each other I go around schools
doing that Gordon Ramsay no
yes he'd been at that school and they
gave me their school tie and I said well
I'm going on the granddaughter and I'll
wear the type so I had to wear it so
there that's for cooking knives they
also get me these borders who approve of
gay people coming out and being honest
about themselves where these to show
their support when they get roles like
this they have to say oh yeah no it's a
thrill dude but for you if this is
genuine because you post these
incredibly sweet pictures this is you as
a young boy
this one this is amazing you were I
think back in your house and you found
this was genuinely yours that was my
first ever spider-man costume yeah which
my lovely mom who said tonight kept for
me and you're one of those kids you like
wore to funerals and weddings still
stinks today that can make that thing
wearable so Emily are your kids how are
they with it
well I think um I mean my youngest my
two year old has a sort of attention
span of a fly so she watches the trailer
but hazel who's almost five has seen it
and just absolutely loved it and sort of
wants to talk about it all the time now
and yeah that was really if your
mother's Mary Poppins I do think she see
I think she just thinks it's normal
she's like well that's what this is what
Sunny's mummy does and this is what my
mummy does you know it's just sort of
like quite conversational for her
is it gonna help or hinder discipline at
home Oh hinder really yeah I think so
because she knows she already knows I
can't fly she's like what she's baby but
she did ask me to do the voice the other
day just out of nowhere because she was
quite sort of impassive watching the
film just sort of didn't just sort of
didn't reveal much of what she felt and
then the other day she goes do your
she's American of course sounds American
she good she good she goes do Mary
Poppins voice and I go spit-spot and off
we go and she goes
and they quite like impregnating me in
the bathtub well where I say to the to
the dolphin no no not yet and now the
two of them go no not yet you like the
premiere of your film monuments man yeah
yeah yeah with a we're drinking
champagne we have just seven great yes
yeah in fact now why is yours not in a
champagne glass you you want people to
think I'm just a man of the people a
simple white wine from me no I just like
drinking more than anyone else at one
time
one two
Wow ginger ale is crazy
now you should ask us really personal
questions big crowd down in Leicester
Square and I just want that Matt it's so
old but people confuse you they don't
always know that you're Matt Damon
that's yeah no they I get I get confused
with Mark Wahlberg it happened last week
I was in New York and I was taking my
kids to the park and and this guy at the
subway I walked by him and he goes Mark
Wahlberg kept walking you know and we
were dancing I was going to Washington
Square Park I'm on Broadway and he's
like I see you Mark Walter and he might
have been a little drunk but but he it
was one of those things where he wasn't
gonna let it go and I'm holding two of
my kids hands it's you know and he's
just you know don't turn around mark we
all know it's you turn around cuz I'm
not Mark Wahlberg but now everybody's
looking and and so I turned the corner
with the kids to get around the corner
he comes running around the corner and
he comes up to me and he goes you know
come on you got to turn around and fry I
turn around and the kids are totally
confused and I go how are you and he
goes I'm good man and that's it and
that's all he wanted he was Mark
Wahlberg and another woman comes running
up and says I love your work and I love
your brothers work as well so I said I
will be sure to tell Donnie Wahlberg and
that was the extent of my interaction
him too cuz somebody posted this
ice-cream aptamer and he didn't correct
us at all
I talked about it years ago and and
because it was happening to us all the
time and so we have a deal and the deal
is just if you're mistaken for the other
guy you have to be extremely polite I
can't ruin his name so when I'm Mark
Wahlberg I have to be on my best back to
confuse with Mark Wahlberg tonight okay
unless you sit in my lap and play with
my nipples fresh prints rad eight
million YouTube hits was on that I can
see your face you like what has he left
well this time I brought my DJ Jazzy
Jeff
[Applause]
[Music]
here we go here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh finished yeah Jeff I don't think that
better already
[Applause]
[Music]
there's another treat for you John
little treat for you a tree
[Applause]
[Music]